happy to welcome alex dean who's the
co-founder and ceo of snowplow analytics
in london
and alex and i met in person about a
year ago
last november it was a pre-pandemic
when we were able to shake hands and
um have coffees um without mouse on so
that was
in the day you know those those back in
the day
i saw a t-shirt that said um remember
the precedented
times uh so i thought you know
that helps me be grateful for uh for
what we used to have
um so alex welcome um thanks for joining
us and
i'm super happy thank you great great to
be here very happy to
be talking to you today
so as is typical um alex i think you
know how we operate
uh dc thursdays but um we do
have a live audience and so we like to
open the
the the wires if you will um for
questions from the community so
the community is active and um might be
dropping in with questions for you
from time to time so we'll work those in
as we can um so
i definitely want to like we have so
many interesting things to talk about
um the origin story of snowplow
um you know lots of other cool things
but
i know that sort of one of the key
differentiators and things that snowplow
talks about a lot
is this notion of behavioral data so
i wanted to ask you first just to set
the stage for a conversation um
what what is behavioral data what what
do you mean by that
and how to define it exactly yeah that's
a that's a great chimpy
and we've we've done a lot of work
recently at snowplow to kind of get a
lot clearer on what behavioral data is
and
start kind of talking much more broadly
about it and it's been really helpful
for us to
to kind of be clear that snow power is
all about behavioral data and that so
that's our big focus i've got a couple
of slides on this i don't want to kind
of
um you know i don't want to sort of
drown us in
in slidewear or anything crazy like that
but you know data's a big space we we
know that here
really well um i think that a big point
that we stressed at snowplows we're all
about the first party data so all about
the data that the companies collect
themselves not the kind of third party
data that you often add into your
warehouse or lake alongside
um and then we're kind of clear that
within first body data
you have a lot of stateful data so the
kind of stuff that you pull out of your
crm or point of sale or erp system and
you use things like stitch or phytran
to get that um but you also have this
super granular event data you know like
the the miniature facts of every single
thing that happened
um and then within that kind of event
data the thing we focus on is behavior
so predominantly that's kind of customer
behavior it's people behaviors it's user
behaviors
um and so that's what we mean when we
talk about behavioral data so
you know we take the the big broad
church of kind of all data we narrow it
down to first party data
then we look at the kind of event data
that's recording kind of the history of
everything that's happened
and then we look at the stuff within
that that relates to
behavior and people's behavior so not
for example um
time series data or iot data or things
like that we're
pretty much focused on the kind of
behavior of people
got it and um what's your origin story
through
this journey of um of the importance of
behavioral data
you've been running snowplow since 2012
and um i'm sure there's some interesting
backstory
uh and personal story as to how you
actually started to realize
this was an important type of data yeah
it's a it's um
it's it's a it's a long old history
really so um so yali and i
started snowplow as the open source
project back in back in 2012.
we'd met at an ad tech firm in 2007 we'd
left we've done consulting in london
and we've been doing a lot of analytics
projects and kind of what we realized
was that our clients had
great kind of stateful data great you
know they could give us great extracts
from their point of sale and
and all those kinds of databases but
when it came to the kind of
behavioral data back then it was often
called clickstream data
but when it came to that they didn't
really have anything so they'd give us
like a login into google analytics and
say go in there and get what you need
but that's not what we wanted we wanted
like
you know every single page view every
single button click all that kind of
stuff
and so that was kind of how we started
it we we sort of knew how to build those
pipelines
um and the original thought was well why
don't we build it again
and this time we'll open source it so
we'll give it away and say look you
don't have to
you know be a hot startup with a bunch
of data engineers in silicon valley to
have this behavioral data yourself and
you know kind of control it and own it
um and so and how was it specifically
different than click stream data like
what was the
what were the limitations of what you
saw as
the typical ways to access click screen
data at the time
it's a good question so it was it was
more that um
so it was more that kind of in in some
odd tech areas and things like that they
people had built these super granular
pipelines but the challenge was that on
the kind of analytic side of the fence
there were these packaged analytics
tools
and they just did not give you access to
the raw to the raw
extreme data and so kind of the the
innovation in a way we're saying oh
we're like
we could just we could take those
concepts uh and just
you know build them again open source
them and give this kind of engine to
everybody
um to kind of use however they however
apart apart from the attack world
because the tech was probably the only
the only
sector that was really talking about
click stream i mean i remember hearing
about clickstream beta and ad tech but
that seemed to be
you know the only sector of the digital
economy that was really focused on that
yeah i mean ad tech was with super early
adopters of kind of real-time
architectures
of kind of store all the things in
hadoop so so they were you know
a fair few years ahead of the rest of us
got it um and so at this time
um what were the other big analytics
tracking
systems for web stuff was this limited
to
google analytics and omniture or were
there other other things in play as well
yeah it was folks like that so web
analytics is a very mature category
um google analytics ga we sometimes call
it an
omniture now adobe analytics but the
with the the big dogs
um we as we were building snowplow
mobile analytics started becoming a big
thing so you know we started to see the
rise of things like kissmetrics and then
mix panel
um folks like that um and then kind of
i think that the other way that uh
package analytics has evolved since is
being with people like heap and
amplitude so
you package analytics tools have
continued to evolve um
what we've continued to do is kind of
give people the give people the engines
that speak the kind of the actual
mechanics to to to run this stuff
themselves and
and solve their own problems on top of
the data
and i guess one of the interesting
things i think about your story
that's particularly interesting is that
um you started the company
from a consulting shop if i recall is
that right you were doing
analytics consulting and i suppose a
decent amount of
um bespoke analytics capture and sort of
schema creation for
clients um talk to us about that that
stage
the the sort of the pre-stage of the
company and how that gave birth to the
product
yeah so that's exactly right so um after
after ellie and i left open x we did
consulting in london
we we ran our own little consultancy
called kepler and that was how we
started to figure out these
these problems and challenges around
kind of behavioral data
and so basically we then kind of came up
with the idea for snowplow we did it in
a kind of a
slightly uh eccentric christmas
hackathon style thing
uh so kind of came up with the the
genesis of that
um open sourced it created a new company
to
to to house um snowplow and to start
developing the
the the project and the community and
kind of went from there so
we essentially wound down the
consultancy for a couple of years
whilst we were kind of building up the
project and
started and we were starting to do
consulting um as snowplow around the
project
and so that was that was quite nice
because it gave us it gave us a bit
longer to kind of figure out
project community fit which is the sort
of open source version of product market
fit and
i think it gave us a little bit longer
to figure that stuff out
and um you know there's a lot there's a
lot of great open source data startups
today and they're they're coming out of
the stables really quickly they're
raising money really quickly
i think we had a bit we were quite early
to to look at behavioral data and so we
had a little bit longer to kind of
experiment and sort of figure out what
this what this project could be
yeah um absolutely i think you're
probably uh
a forerunner of many of the other
companies that we've seen emerge over
the last couple of years i think of
um dbt who did consulting as fishtown
analytics
yeah very cheap i think of super
conductive behind great expectations
that did consulting before they
um birthed their open source project um
in your case would you say that
getting open source traction was a key
aspect of the early stage of the company
or was it was the open source just
um did it just sort of happen to come
along with the fact that you had built
this
cool tool you were using it in client
deployments so basically you're using it
for commercial use
and you sort of also wanted to just see
what the community thought about it or
was the open source adoption like a core
part of
of your strategy at the time no open
source adoption is a really cool part
so our um it turned out that our kind of
clients in london weren't
quite advanced enough to need snowplow
yet and so our kind of most exciting
early adopters were not
like we're not our consulting clients as
um london so
so yeah right out the door so out the
door we got some early pick up so it was
kind of these
sort of data mavericks data macgyver
characters and there are a lot of
startups and scale ups occasionally
inside enterprises as well
um like i think we got early adoption
inside like vodafone and bauer and
places
and so they would find plow and they
would sort of figure out that it could
solve their specific problem and bring
snowplow in and
and like i think in the early days of an
open source project
people like that those kind of mavens
are your they're your oxygen like you
need those people you need those people
to be really excited about you
to kind of keep going and keep building
this thing so so no
those early adopters like you know we we
know them all still and and
you know we're very grateful to them and
and they're a big part of the story
and and being open source was a big part
of the story so
you know we there were all these
different um
analytics vendors packaged analytics
vendors proprietary vendors
being built and continuing to mean build
um and we knew that on the other side of
the fence we knew that enterprises were
building these kind of pipelines
internally themselves kind of home
brewing them
um and so so that the fact that snowplow
was open source
was the kind of innovation in a way it
wasn't a completely normal architecture
but
this thing being out there being apache2
license was was kind of
was the secret source in a way so you
you bootstrapped the company for a while
through consulting revenues
you launched the open source you started
to see some open source adoption
um when did you raise your first round
of venture funding
so we only raised that last year so
august 2019.
um so what do we do kind of in between
so um we actually
moved we actually brought in a
commercial model in 2015 so we've done
kind of consulting until
and in 2015 we we we wanted to keep
growing but we
we wanted to stay bootstrapped at that
time so we looked around at different
commercial models and
the thing we stumbled on which was quite
interesting was and we played around
with a few different ones so we tried
out hosted we tried out a couple of
other things
but the thing that people really wanted
from us which is interesting was
they wanted snowplow they kind of heard
about it maybe they'd had you know had a
friend and another data team who was
running it
um so they wanted snowplow they wanted
it inside their own aws account
so snowplow runs like natively on aws
and also now on google cloud
they wanted it inside their own account
but they didn't know how to run it
and so they would come to us to to kind
of they pay us to run it for them in
their own account
and you know back then we called that a
kind of a managed service
today we call it private sas and it's
still the the primary thing people buy
from us and it's
and people really like it they really
like the ownership they like the fact
that this behavioral data is theirs and
it's inside their own account
but they like the fact that we'll run it
for them um so we call that snowplow
insights and and that's what we've been
selling since 2015 and and that's what
bootstrapped us up until uh until we
raised money last year
you got it and did anything change with
the company
perceptibly once you raised venture um
any
lessons to other founders out there who
might have a choice to either
go this bootstrap route or raise money i
mean
from my perspective it seems like every
founder wants wants to bootstrap
and in my opinion many founders
bootstrap far too long
um if they have the option to raise
venture um
but you know that's not always the case
i'm curious to sort of hear what your
feedback would be for folks out there
who might be thinking about starting
something on their own
yeah i think i think it's a great i
think this is such a fun topic
like um there's a lot of there's a lot
of founders who like bootstrapping we
really enjoyed bootstrapping
i've noticed there's not a lot of
founders who bootstrapped twice so it's
like
a lot of founders so the second time
around they're like okay i'm just gonna
raise money and do this thing
um but um i will probably get lots of
comments saying no that's not true
there's loads of
like cereal bootstrappers uh what do i
think uh i think for us
and a really important part of of the
fundraise and then
getting the capital to deploy into the
business
was actually about kind of raising our
awareness so you know we had
we got the kind of project community fit
fairly early
fairly early doors at snowplow probably
like 2013-14
and we we we started to get this product
market fit in sort of 2016-17
but then you know you know this well
people like 2018 the whole cloud data
market went crazy
and just really really blew up and you
know it's very
it's really funny looking back on it
because you know we've had the snowflake
thing and all these different events
this year
but you know it was a lot sleepier a
couple of years ago and then it started
getting big and so for us really
the fundraising and the fact we've been
able to be out there much more you know
sponsoring events
like you know speeding up our roadmap
all that stuff it's just helped us a lot
with awareness across
data teams like you know for us the most
important thing is that when data teams
are trying to
solve behavioral data problems they a
realize
that's a class a problem and they b
realize that snowflower exists and
you know they can either buy snapchat
insights or they can just use our open
source but
you know every time every time someone i
find someone who's homebrewed all this
stuff in
2020 i'm like and you haven't heard of
snowplow i'm like ah
like that's the problem solved so yeah
fundraising's been super helpful on that
yep got it well um let's get into the
the actual product because i know folks
out there are curious
about um you know insights and the way
snowball works
and the architecture and all those
things so
um i i have to say that i found your
website like quite
quite well done um i don't know if uh
if if if this is the the venture capital
money network
um on on a augmented marketing team
um but i found that you know there's
lots of info on use cases
and um the products and um
ways to think about data um so yeah i
found it super helpful
and i just wanted to call out you know
some of the use cases that you think of
in terms of um top of mind for for your
customers um what
like why do people look for and find a
snow plow when there's a
plethora of other options yeah and
that's such a good question and that's
that's a question we've done
a ton of thinking on this year so you
know we've had we've had a lot of
adoption over the years
but actually getting to the heart of
like why did like you said there's all
these different things out there there's
lots of package tools there's lots of
like diy
options like why do people use snowplow
and where we kind of
where we've come to on that and then i
think we're super clear on it now um
is that people come to us because there
are use cases they want to solve
um that are kind of part of powered by
the modern data stack
they have a behavioral data component so
like that's why sort of they're knocking
on the snowplow door
and and the really important thing is
that they want to kind of build those
use cases
themselves so you know to give an
example we have a lot of customers that
that do um product analytics with
snowplow behavioral data
and there's great like packaged product
analytics tools out there
so why are they using snowplow and and
it tends to be that there's just
something about their product analytics
that needs to be bespoke to their
business and they can't just use the
kind of cookie cutter
uh tools that they that their
competitors are using and so they sort
of figure out that they can use snowplow
and so
yeah we started putting a lot of use
cases on the sites and we'll add a lot
more we've got like a library of 34 of
them now
um but i think the key point is you know
there's different ones are used by
different people marketing attribution
is quite hot at the moment
um in this kind of covered world like
deep subscriber insights and kind of
churn reduction is a really hot use case
as well
but i think that the core thing everyone
has in common is people have decided
that they want to build these use cases
themselves as their own data products
you know on top of bigquery or snowflake
or redshift or maybe on a data lake or
maybe on an event stream
um but they want to kind of own that
themselves and and you know it's
important enough to their business that
they want to put their data team you
know data teams are expensive resources
right but they want to put their data
team on that problem to solve
because that that's just too important
to their business um
that's kind of what we figured out this
year but you know i think a lot of
um a lot of tech technologies and and
vendors in the data space
i think i think it's the same for a lot
of us but i think we've done a bit of
work on that and we started building out
the use cases and stuff like that so
yeah we're super excited about that side
of things
yeah it seems to me like as a developer
it seems like one of the
um core differences that you guys offer
that's significant
is the ability to have bespoke custom
schemas and data structures and where i
as an engineer
i can define what the data looks like
you know that that snowplow captures and
i can sort of conform that to my own
schema my undesired schema instead of
being at the mercy
of whatever schema is delivered to me by
some other vendor is that a is that a
big selling point
yeah it's a big it's a big part of it so
like when you're working with
um when you're working with first party
data and you're working with the the
behavioral data that's being generated
off your
assets so your websites mobile apps um
you know
systems like that server-side systems as
well but by definition you're working
with your business
entities so you're working with you know
your definition of the customer or your
definition of like a trade or your
definition of like a used car for sale
and so uh yeah we we put kind of schema
technology into snowplow quite
like really early doors i think it was
sort of 2004 it was around the same time
that um
the the confluent guys were getting
started with with avra and stuff as well
and that that technology is really
important because it lets companies
express kind of yeah their business
entities um which is really important
and then
i would say that the um the associated
uh
rise has been on the other end of the
pipeline where like everyone now is
really understanding the importance of
working with all that granular data and
sort of modeling it up into something
that's
that's that's meaningful for the
business and so that's kind of why
data modeling is super important
analytics engineering has become a big
career
dbt is like super valuable and and so
all of this is speaking to like yeah
companies want to sort of bespoke
model their business end to end
got it um so on the on the ingest side
um you have connectors that plug into an
assortment of different
things to get the data into snowplow in
the first place
um are those connectors open sourced or
how did you
what was your strategy on sort of
building those connectors i'm curious
yeah so um i brought up this kind of
slightly intimidating
noisy technology diagram in case it's
helpful um but but yeah no
you're right so um we started with um so
we started with web
because that was our kind of our home
game that was what we were interested in
to start with
so we did web tracking um then we got
into mobile
um and then we started adding a bunch of
server side trackers as well and we did
some other stuff as well like some
third-party web hooks from
places like zendesk and mail
mailchimp and things like that but yeah
i mean we started with web all
the sdks um are open source
i mean the whole the whole kind of data
transit layer is actually open source so
the whole of this diagram kind of
getting it from the sources
getting it through the processing and
then into the warehouse
all of that is is is open source um
but but yeah the trackers are super
important that's where the sort of data
starts
got it um and so how is a
behavioral data pipeline different than
a
regular data pipeline i think i think
you've brought up before that some of
your customers
run snowplow in parallel to other etl
systems like 5tran um
why why does that exist and sort of how
do you differentiate um or how do you
think about that
yeah it's a it's a really good question
so basically the way
the way we think of snowplow is snowplow
is um
it's a it's a real-time kind of
event-based architecture
that's opinionated about behavioral data
so it's got you know the
it's got the tracking sdks it does like
enrichment stuff and schematization
stuff in the middle and then it kind of
flows through
um so it's i think there's a few
different things to compare it to
so it's not um so lots of our customers
use stitch
or five tran alongside we don't do um
we don't do etl so we don't go and grab
um you know the the latest
um customer record out of salesforce or
do like you know
nightly or hourly syncs into different
um crm systems or anything like that so
a lot of our customers will use
something like that alongside we don't
do change data capture either so a lot
of people
might use something like division as
well alongside i guess because snowplow
flows the behavioral data through into
the warehouse or the lake um
people will you can still you know
you're using the lake or the warehouse
as your kind of central repository and
so you know if you have other tools that
are flowing other data
side piping other things in that's
that's totally fine as well so you know
i mean there are some sort of
philosophical differences i guess some
of the etl tools are more so batch based
um things like that um but i mean
fundamentally like
we're a we're a real-time pipeline
designed for behavioral data
and just for clarity that also means we
kind of sit a level
higher than like uh you know a
confluence stack or
or lenses delay or anything like that
because those are or stream sets
those are general purpose toolkits for
building
um real-time pipelines whereas we are
like
uh we're more like a platform layer
we're an opinionated layer end to end
you don't have to
you know to run snowplow end to end you
don't have to write any code yourself
you can create schemas and things and do
some sequel data modelling downstream
but um it's
we're not a we're not a programmers
toolkit got it
well since we have the the diagram up um
do you want to walk us through the
architecture so that folks have a
better understanding of how it works and
to end sure thing sure thing so um
so yeah so let's get started so on the
left hand side we've got um
our different behavioral data sources
that we talked about a little bit
earlier
those all emit um snow power events kind
of raw events
into our collector from the collector we
hand it over to uh kind of a processing
job and the processing job does two
things so it does
uh validation of the data and then it
does enrichment so
the validation is important so you know
a way to think of it is these tracking
sources are a little bit unreliable like
you don't necessarily know if your
mobile app developer has has um
structured the the events in the right
way
and so the first thing we do is we do
validation so we check that
the events are conformed to the schemas
that they should
should uh should do so those schemas
will live in a schema registry
they're all json schemas the events that
come in are self-describing which means
the event says
i should map on to you know um add to
basket version
102 kind of thing and and then so if i
can validate that that data is correct
um and then we uh we have a happy path
so the happy path is the data moves on
to enrich and then we have an
unhappy path uh where the events that
fail validation go into bad stream and
then they get stored so that you can
look at them and hopefully recover them
if they're if they're kind of important
to the business
basically recovering them means fixing
them and then sending them back into the
front of the pipe
um after validation we do enrichment so
basically enrichment is like
widening widening the data so that's
where we add other sort of data sources
so
you know we do like ip lookups we can
check if um
an event is coming from a bot or a
spider
we can look up the weather we can pull
from um
a database um and the enrichment phase
is really interesting because
we we had to build it really early um in
in the snowplow history
we started building snowplow and we
didn't have any enrichment
and analysts were coming to us and they
were saying this is great the data's
really granular but i can't work with it
like i need to
you know the first thing i want to do is
do like you know um
my my website visitors by jio we were
like ah okay so we just kept adding more
enrichments as we went along
so this is where your third-party data
fits in yeah exactly
so this is where we kind of pull in like
max mind and iab bots and spiders and
stuff like that
um so then we kind of got a much fatter
event
uh validate is valid and it's and it's
been enriched it's got more data in it
um then we uh kick it out to a good
stream
so this will sit um in in kinesis for
aws or
google cloud pub sub for google cloud um
and then we've got a good stream and
then from there we sync the good stream
into
uh redshift snowflake and bigquery
are super popular we can also put it
into elasticsearch
uh we can put it into um s3 and google
cloud storage as well
um so those are kind of the big stores
and then once it's there once this
super granular data is there then our
users and our customers work with it
um and that's where the data modeling
piece comes in
so we um we did we did some really good
early work on data modeling and back in
the day
but then we kind of we spent a lot of
time in the last couple years really
focusing on the the earlier part of the
pipeline doing the port to aws from aws
to gcp
but we've come back into data modeling
in a big way in the last few months so
we've got um
we've got a uh we created a new official
web data model so it basically takes all
the web events and and
basically aggregates them makes them
easier to work with
you know turn sort of individual heart
beats on a page into kind of
page view time and stuff like that and
so we we're building that out for
redshirt bigquery and snowflake
um we're also working on a mobile model
to do the same
the same stuff at the moment they're raw
sequel but um but yeah we're looking to
kind of
create some dbt bindings and things like
that just to kind of um
make them more more uh more broadly
useful
um so yeah that's that's kind of the end
to end let's talk about the
the bad stream because i have a feeling
that there's some story there
where um everybody wants a system to to
operate
um as designed 100 of the time but you
clearly have a
designed path in the system for events
that failed validation i think it says
there
um how do folks use that and when did it
occur to you that it was important to
capture those events as well
that's a good question so it it occurred
to us to do it really really early doors
so we we'd been very frustrated
with the packaged analytics tools back
in back in um
kind of 2010 around then we've been
really frustrated that like if
if your tracking went wrong the data
just went missing
and we just wasted so much time trying
to sort of track down where that stuff
had gone and and sort of unpiecing that
so it was it was really important to us
really early on that this pipeline was
kind of unidirectional that the data was
immutable throughout it
and that like bad data wasn't just
silently dropped but it was like
you know it was always put out to
different places and you know i think
that i think that the closest equivalent
is
is unix right with like standard in
standard out and standard uh like
it's just i think it's very sensible to
have a to have a failure path
and um and yeah and so the way people
use it is
um if if they've got data that's missing
and we're starting to do some alerting
in the in the kind of paid for
snow power but if data's missing then
they'll kind of go in they'll
look at the failed events the failed
events have like
uh the the reasons why they couldn't be
processed so like you know
um this this add to basket uh failed
validation because it's
you know the the the value of it is a
string instead of a number or whatever
um so you can see all the failure or the
failure messages and then
people people will write like a little
lambda function or something like that
to clean it up and get it back into the
back into the stream if it's important
enough they might just say okay that's
fine that was that was testing mode
let's move on sometimes i suppose they
could discover ways that their schema
maybe isn't as tight as they as they
thought yeah very could be sort of
iteration iterations over the schema
right based on what you're seeing in
that field event pile
yeah and that's been a big part of
snowfall so we did um
we did schema versioning and evolution
really early on because
we knew that we knew that like people
wanted to make changes to schemas to
entities and we knew that people wanted
to make breaking changes as well
um and that all of that needed to happen
kind of without the pipeline braking
without you needing to bring up
components
bring down components and i think we had
to
it's kind of interesting we had to solve
that really early because
we were building a you know a general
purpose
pipeline that lots of different
companies could use i think a lot of
data teams took
shortcuts on that stuff because they
were just solving this for their company
and their entities
so i think you know there's a lot of
pipelines out there's a lot of homebrew
pipelines out there that have kind of
ad impression v1 ad impression v2 kind
of hard
hard baked into them yep makes sense
and so this architecture has this
changed significantly
over time or how has this evolved yeah
it's it's it's evolved a fair bit so um
the original version of snowplow was uh
pretty much a fully
well it was a batch architecture so in
the
early version of snowplow which was aws
only
uh the collection was like a
microservice http mic service but then
actually the
the validate and enrich was a um an
elastic map reduced job so
you know amazon flavored hadoop job and
our
our customers and users would just um
they just bring up a
emr cluster do the processing and shut
it down again
which was kind of a bit slow and clunky
but it was actually really cheap
um because it just was a um especially
on kind of
medium-sized volumes and things like
that so so that was the early
architecture
um even even as we were sort of you know
building that and maintaining that uh
you know the whole the
the whole there's so much innovation
going on around real time so obviously
kafka was
was going great guns a kinesis came out
and so we knew that we wanted to
re-platform and turn it into a kind of a
real-time microservices architecture and
and we did that
um we did that kind of 2015
to 2018 and when we interestingly when
we did the google cloud port
like we didn't even think about doing
anything batch based we just built that
as like
um you know data flow modules and things
like that that just run all that run all
the time
got it and so um
can can i see or can we can we see here
from
what what the difference is between the
open source version
and and the the commercial version or
does the open source consider all these
components
include all these components it's just
more of a managed service yeah it's a
great question so this diagram
is um is just for now the um
uh the open source um i might have let
me see i might have um
a different version of this um
do i have a different version i don't
have a different version of this um to
hand pete but
but fundamentally um step out insights
the commercial version
there's two there's two extra layers to
it so
there's a there's a pretty chunky kind
of under the water
um devops and data ops layer to to snap
that inside so we do a lot of like
automation
monitoring auto scaling all of that kind
of stuff
and you know i think people forget auto
scaling is not about kind of
bringing the architecture up quickly or
it's not just that it's also just like
bringing it down after the big you know
black friday traffic spike and all that
kind of stuff so
so we do a lot of that stuff for the
customer base um
and then the other thing which is which
is really fun is we've been building out
a
ui to help um to help our customers with
kind of
basically work with the behavioral data
in their organization some of our
customers are in you know very big
complex organizations
multiple data teams all that kind of
stuff um and so we we do it we do quite
a lot there to help them with
the schemas and kind of creating and
evolving the entities
um so that's a big part of it and we're
starting to do more now around the kind
of the the data modeling side of it so
like how do you actually
work with the super granular data and
get it ready for
you know get it ready for a dbt or a
looker or
whatever um off downstream so so yeah
that's that's the ui that we've we've
built on top and
um uh and yeah that's that's only for
that's proprietary it's not part of the
open source but the whole data transit
layer is open source
got it let's see um cool well that's uh
yeah thanks for running through that
with us
um that's really interesting to hear how
the architecture has
how it works and how it's um evolved
over time um
so i guess the other question i had was
sort of related to the other competitors
um how does snowplow compare to some of
the other
um customer data platforms that are in
the space i think of segment
or perhaps on particle or others
it's a great question and it's a super
confusing and crowded market as
you as you know i think that um you know
it's a really it's
it's a complicated market and you know
customer data platforms
have been a big big trend in the last
couple of years and i think there's been
a
lot
of data teams trying to figure out you
know do they need a
cdp like maybe their marketing team has
been talking to them like we need a cdp
and they're like but haven't we been
building all this kind of
you know data infrastructure ourselves
for the last few years so it's a it's a
really
interesting complicated space i think
that for us we sort of
split the cdps out in a couple of
different ways so
um i think there's there's clearly cdps
that are doing a lot of work to kind of
help activate
the the data and the decisions and and
kind of take all that behavioral data
and other like you know transactional
data and stuff
and kind of help um help marketers help
marketing teams help kind of tech savvy
marketing teams to
you know do identity resolution and then
like segment those
those those visitors and customers and
then like activate it on different
marketing platforms and to be clear we
don't we don't do that side of things so
you know
we're all about kind of getting people
the super granular behavioral data
getting it into their warehouse and
their lake so they can start to solve
their use cases and they may well not be
marketing use cases that want to solve
with no power
so we see those sort of we see that as
one part of the cdp market
we see segment and then particle as more
like these kind of
uh marketing data integrators so they
kind of do
they do behavioral data like snowplow
but they also do like some other stuff a
bit more like stitch and five trans to
get other kind of marketing data sources
in
and then they do a bit of identity
resolution and they do a bit of
segmentation and they
they're used by marketers as well so i
think kind of
if you squint like a lot of the same
technology is present in a snowplow as
it is in say a segment or an m particle
but we are kind of more focused on the
data team and we have
a lot of like non-marketing use cases um
whereas i think i think they often are
kind of brought in a bit more to kind of
do the plumbing and kind of do the
connectivity between a lot of different
sources many of which you like marketing
sources so
yeah it's a it's a complicated market um
i think for us
like we want to spend a bit more time
kind of figuring out how
snowpack can integrate into some of
these cdp's so that people can
understand
you want you want to control your own
awesome behavioral data
but then sure for your marketing team
you do want to let them plug in and
self-serve with kind of
you know segment builders and things
like that well do you think um based on
this
these distinctions do you think the
buyer is different um between
the segment buyer versus the the snow
plow
buyer i mean it because you have the
open source package and because you
are sort of approachable by data
engineers and because you can be
quickly adopted by somebody without
getting you know budget budget authority
from above
um do you find that you sort of grow up
through the data infrastructure
type team and sort of then bubble up
into
you know paid offerings inside the
client like i'm curious what the
customer journey
looks like from that respect yeah that's
that's that's spot on
so we um because of the open source and
and because we've been around a long
time and sort of talking about a lot of
the problems that
data engineers and data teams face like
you know data quality and observability
and real time and things like that yeah
you're right we get sort of picked up
and spotted by a lot of kind of data
teams and
um you know a lot of those kind of data
mavericks and macgyvers from our early
days they're now
um heads of data so they now had like
headed data or head of analytics or
header data engineering or ops
so so yeah they they kind of bring
snowplow in whereas i
think often the kind of more packaged
sort of customer data tools
i think they're often kind of more
brought in by sort of head to digital
and
you know um commercially mine
commercially savvy ctos or technically
savvy cmos people like that so that's my
that's my rough read but i think you
know it's such a it's such a
it's such a crazy space and it's growing
so fast i think we see a bit of
everything in the
in the customer base yep got it
well um alex i know you have some
thoughts regarding
sort of the modern ecosystem in regards
to
data lakes data warehouse
and some of these new fangled
architectures that are
being thrown at at us at teams
at businesses i'm curious to hear your
thoughts on that
in general because you've been in this
space for a long time
um and i kind of feel like you probably
have some things to say
regarding data warehouses eating the
world um et cetera
uh yeah look it's a it's a really fun
topic and uh we
we we chew the fat on it a fair bit yali
and i talk about it
quite a lot as well and i think it's
it's fun to have been in the space a
long time
um and i like we've been in the space a
long time like um i
um my first job after uni was doing kind
of classic
um data warehousing projects etl
projects for uh
for deloitte in london like kind of old
school kind of you know
kimball star system stuff so i've seen
i've seen multiple generations of it
um what do i think i think i think
there's a few interesting things going
on
so i mean we talked about how we
re-platformed snowplows in real time and
that was totally the right thing to do
and we we're a big believer in real-time
architectures there's some great
real-time use cases
but having said that i think it's
interesting how um
how kind of dominant the big cloud data
warehouses that are not real-time
architectures
are it's it's it's it's interesting how
sort of dominant they are today and
you know i think um redshifts maybe
handed the bats on a bit to snowflake
but snowflake is doing
great guns bigquery is doing really well
um
and you know like i started i started
hearing from heads of data about
18 months ago who was saying things like
we're just we're kind of ripping out the
the spark code and some of the kind of
you know kafka streams jobs and stuff
and we're just putting it all into
snowflake it's just we're just writing a
lot of sequel and
you know kind of putting on slightly
crappy cron jobs and things like that
but like
it was just it you know it wasn't real
time but it was it was cheap and it was
it was it was fast and
i think i think it's i think it's
interesting if you'd asked me a couple
years ago i would have said real time
would
would come along faster and um it's been
really interesting seeing kind of
the rise and rise of the warehouses i
think that
um i i don't i don't have a horse in the
race
in on on data lakes and you know that
they attract such strong opinions one
way or the other around like
you know data swamps and schema data
versus you know uncurated stuff and all
that stuff i do
like the data bricks guys seem to be
doing really well um we have
people talking to us about like asking
for like delta lake integration for
snowplow and things like that so
i i suspect they'll end up being like
the last the last big
data lake and and and people will
continue to love it and use it
um i think materialize they just
announced that series b
i think i think that's super interesting
there's a there's something missing in
our stacks around real time there's just
something missing around kind of
easy low cost development of use cases
on top of real time
we've had like you know customers build
some really cool use cases using like
lambda functions and dynamodb
and all that kind of stuff but it's
quite cl it's a bit clunky and it's like
difficult to do and it takes time so i
think there's something missing there
um but but no i mean i think the big i
think the big story is that is is the
big story that everyone knows about
which is just the
you know the workloads are moving to the
cloud data warehouses and
you know i think i think that the thing
i can't figure out but i'm excited about
is how quickly do the data products move
there as well and
you know how quickly do do we all start
building our
all our use cases inside of inside of a
snowflake or
a big query but that seems to be the
trend that seems to be the direction of
travel
yeah it makes me wonder how long that
will last and when we'll regret it
it seems like things move in cycles
right and when i was an engineer
um in the first internet bubble um you
know we were starting to get away from
all these triggers inside databases
yeah yeah still procedures remove remove
all of our application logic from inside
the database because that was the
worst possible thing um you know for it
was hard to debug and
it was difficult for for performance and
it was just you know there were all
these sort of concerns about
like how that worked and so we were
fighting to decouple
the logic like out of the database and
now i feel like we're dangerously close
to just shoving it all back in there and
calling you know just calling it a data
lake instead
but you're you're right and it's so
you're right it's so cyclical and you
see the same thing with with business
intelligence as well it's
always like it's always oscillating
every few years between kind of
self-service and then like
it becomes a bit chaotic and like
different versions of the kpis and then
everyone centralizes again
then it becomes too service dusky and
people can't get their metrics and it
goes back to
back to self-service so it's yeah we're
very cyclical data is a very sectional
industry i truly agree
yeah well it'll be interesting to see
how it all shakes out
um well so on on the snow plow company
building front
um do you have any any
particular things that you wanted to add
i know your team is growing and
there's lots lots of things going on in
that front i'm curious
who you're hiring and what what types of
folks you look for as you continue to
build
out the the snowplow team like who's the
hardest role to find right now
oh that's a really good question um
that's a really good question
um well i think i think in general
there's just
um there's just a shortage of people
who've got a lot of experience in
in cloud data and in these kinds of
architectures so
you know we're we're always uh always
looking to hire great engineers
um you know our our core data
engineering is all kind of um
uh functional programming based scarlet
and and those those those people are
really hard to find
um our model is still this kind of
private sas model so we we manage a
a huge kind of estate of of production
snowplows around the world and so we're
always looking for great um
infrastructure talent that's uh that's
tough as well but um
yeah i think i think it's it's it
everyone everyone's yeah we did a
webinar the other day and it was like
everyone was hiring at the end of it and
it's a truism but i think that
um but i think also that's kind of why
all us
technology vendors exist because nobody
has enough data engineers nobody has
enough data scientists nobody has enough
analytics engineers so the more the
the more that we can build so that
people don't have to to build this stuff
themselves like
i saw that 5 tran had put out a bunch of
dbt models recently i thought
that's really sensible because like now
a load of different
analytics engineers don't have to write
those dbt models
um so yeah we're always looking for
talent um we we used to be kind of
um mixed mode with kind of uh half the
half the company in london and the other
half globally distributed we still
obviously have the london office but um
but we're running we've been running as
like a fully remote
uh company for since uh since march so
um so that's been
that's been fine for us and yeah we hire
all over the place um
but yeah it's uh i think it's tough for
everyone hiring moment it's just a
it's crazy market yeah that's funny so
we're talking about data infrastructure
companies as a talent arbitrage
um they exist the the plethora of data
infrastructure companies exist because
it's a talent arbitrage opportunity in
the market
if you're able to hire the folks then
you know you get to build the stuff but
if you can't
if you can yeah it's an engineer then
then you're stuck and you're buying
stuff from snowplow
that's a good place it's a funny way
looking at it um
but yeah i know it's um no it's good and
uh um
i think other things other things that
we're looking at um
so we're just starting to hire analytics
engineers which is super fun so we've
never
never had our analytics engineers we've
had like great engineers who've done
that work for us not a great data
modeling but uh but now we're getting
dedicated analytics engineers which is
super fun
um and uh starting to
um think about kind of what our
education team looks like
and um and i think that's that's
actually probably the biggest challenge
for us or
i should say the biggest challenge in
the biggest opportunities so you know
we've done we've done some work this
summer this year figured out the use
cases
but actually each of those use cases it
needs quite a lot of material to kind of
help people understand how to solve this
thing with um
with uh with snowplow so you know good
uh
one one example so like um i was just
writing like the help desk enablement
use case this morning and
if you want to give you know great
insights to your
support team uh to give better support
somehow's a good way of doing it but
like we need to write the blueprint for
that so we need to say to people hey the
way you do this is
you get some product analytics running
with snowplow then you
um talk to your head of support and you
figure out what are the metrics they
need uh then you model that in dbt
and then you use census or um or high
touch to like connect that back out into
zendesk and
you know and that's just one use case so
we've got to do a lot of that stuff to
kind of explain
explain how to build all these use cases
that's great well i'm sure there will be
folks watching this
episode in this video who um will want
to reach out to you
and um and mention that they they heard
that snowplow was hiring here
um that's obviously one of the big needs
the community and and we want to serve
that need at data council is
exposing the best companies um so that
they have a chance to
to hire from our our community and our
audience so
um yeah i'm glad to hear that the
company is growing
and i guess just to to close things off
um
i'm curious since i asked this question
to most folks
what was the thing that surprised you
most uh about building snowplow
as such that is such a good question let
me
ah let me think for a minute
what surprised me what surprised me most
oh i don't know p i think
it takes it takes a long
i think i have to say this one this is
observation it takes a very long time to
build
like you know a meaningful piece of
technology
um and i think that was you know we
thought we'd be done
when the alien i started send out we
thought we'd do this plumbing thing
for six months we were like you know
we've got these cool problems we want to
solve for our clients
they're missing this behavioral data uh
let's just
do the plumbing and get back to it and
you know that was
that we thought that would be six months
that was like seven and a half seven and
a half years ago like
i think actually like building this
stuff well
and you know like really rigorous like
it yeah it's been a big
it's been a big job so that's been i
think that's been the kind of the
biggest surprise um uh
i think i think the other surprise is
how like effective
open source can be as a way of building
brand and community
like i think people get confused a bit
between you know people get confused
between open source because it's
it has so much in it so people think
about the price point they think about
like
the fact that code can be audited they
think about community and
you know there's there's lots of
different dimensions to open source but
when it works really well you get this
great like word of mouth
and you know people will just people
don't have to learn what it is they can
download it and like poke it with a
stick and
that is that's really valuable it it
creates its own
complexities like it's it's it's
complicated to be a commercial open
source company
um compared to just you know
straightforward public sas um but um but
it's
it's pretty awesome when it works yeah
that's that's so well said i
we're seeing that trend a lot in the
industry and i think there's
so much power behind behind open source
and engineers who yeah definitely choose
to go that route and
um i know i've been coaching and
advising and investing in other open
source companies in the data world who
have an unfair advantage in distribution
because of those open source bits and
the way that they can
sort of flow through the the ether and
and be adopted by teams um who don't
have to worry about the commercial
hurdles
um so there's a lot of power there i
agree um
we actually we actually have a question
that came in um
so in in the spirit of um honoring the
the question from the community someone
is asking about the bad data
not being silently dropped how are
clients monitoring those errors inside
your failed events where do they find
errors
and how do they send it back to the pipe
yeah that's a great that's a great
question so um
it used to be it used to be a bit ad hoc
but we've we've built a fair bit of
tooling around that now and we sort of
we just run process on it looking for
patterns looking for like increases in
the number of bad data
new types of error that we haven't seen
before and then we're working on kind of
alerting and monitoring to
to tell people about that and then kind
of within uh
in terms of event recovery like again
we're kind of working on tooling to make
it easier to
to kind of recover that data and
reprocess it and you know it might be
really simple it might be just fix the
schema in the registry and
run the data through again um but it's
it's
one once you give someone a pipeline
that has a bad you know a bad path an
unhappy path
and once you sort of explain how that
works people are really interested in
that because you know
people don't want that weird
discontinuous drop in their metrics
um some you know people are like using
this stuff for like you know board
reporting for that you know public
reporting so um
so yeah like the answer is uh anomaly
detection
and we're working on more kind of
recovery tooling because it's important
got it well alex thanks for joining us
today
it was really fun to have you and
excited to see the growth of snowplow
um excited to see where the company goes
in the future
thanks so much for having me it's been
awesome yeah it's been great
so uh just to close off um i wanted to
um again thank alex for for joining us
for snowplow for being part of our
community
for the last few years it's been great
to have them around
also thanks to ibm who has been
our global sponsor for data council this
year and
as many of you have come to learn ibm is
a big supporter of open source
and so we invite you to check out the
data science community that has all
kinds of online resources and content
and training
for data scientists um we'll post that
link
in the description so that you can
quickly access that
also don't forget to leave us comments
about today's episode in the forum
there's a feedback form
that we put in the chat so that we make
it super easy for you to just uh
pop in and drop us a couple comments it
helps us
keep the content fresh keep speakers on
that you're interested in
and just improve the overall experience
for dc thursday so
we appreciate you sounding off there
finally i wanted to mention that in the
spirit of helping engineers start
companies
i'm personally interested in talking to
engineers in our community
who have the earliest stage startups or
even ideas
before startups as alex and i discussed
today there's all kinds of challenges
when you start a company as an engineer
and so i make myself available through
office hours regularly to our community
to have conversations with many of you
every week regarding
projects that you have open source tools
or companies that you want to start and
so
um i just want to continue to put myself
out there for the benefit of the
community and
and and give back in that way so please
contact me directly if that's something
that you're interested in taking
advantage of
um so finally if you want to subscribe
to youtube it's always great you hear
about our future episodes
if you click the bell icon um you can
set all your notifications to on so that
you actually see when we go live with
the streams
every other week and that you uh you
don't need to be watching your email
but it's been great to have everybody
thanks again for tuning in
and thanks to alex we'll see you all
next time